c'est le plus gros gain en France cette
année et quelques informations au filtre
la chanceuse jouait occasionnellement
une cinquantenaire qui venait de perdre
son emploi ah bah je suis content pour
elle parce que licencié est gagné nous
sommes comme ça ça tombe bien quand pour
une fois c'est pas toujours ce qui vient
de l'argent qui gagne ce serait 100
millions d'euros je pense ah moi je
pense qu'avec 2
c'est c'est idéal 6 millions en vrai
si en fait la somme moyenne rêvée par
les Français et de 26 millions d'euros
26 millions d'euros c'est énorme quand
on n'a jamais eu trop d'argent on sait
pas quantifié en fait les plus modestes
souhaiteraient plus 45 millions les plus
aisés un peu moins seulement si on peut
dire 17,6 millions la bascule elle se
situe à l'âge de 23 ans on commence à
mourir à partir de l'âge de 23 ans
pourquoi parce que ça correspond selon
eux à l'entrée dans le monde
professionnel en moyenne la courbe du
rire remonte nettement à partir de 65
ans
78% du 18 24 ans rêvent d'être riches
contre seulement 45% des plus de 65 ans
et que choisit-on entre la richesse
l'intelligence ou la beauté
l'intelligence serait pour moi le plus
important l'intelligence pour savoir
bien
la beauté vu ma tronche on s'en fout
c'est un beau
garçon